hello and welcome
frame uh it's being recorded on a friday
night but i am here live
and we're going to be talking about
three reasons you should teach
your knowledge or skill in an online
course i'm so fired up for this
information
because we're going to be talking about
some new statistics that you need to
know about the e-learning industry
a powerful case study of how a
20-year-old college
student built a six-figure business on
the side
by selling online courses i'm going to
answer a bunch of your questions
uh if you're here live and i am super
fired up so smash the like button if
you're ready to get into this
and um this is kind of a crazy
friday party and the topic today is
youtube and online courses
how to create and sell and scale your
own your own
e-course using youtube and let me ask
you have you thought about creating an
online course before have you considered
making one uh have you ever invested in
one or taken one
it's good to see all house josh shock
soccer skills shout me out where are you
watching from let me know
and uh we're gonna dive right into this
but let's kick it off really quick
and you may want to take some notes
there's a lot of information you may
have wondered
what should i make my course about what
should i name it what should i price it
how long should it be what software
should i use there's going to be a lot
in this and so i'm going to download a
bunch of information
in fact joey just asked what's the best
platform to host of course
and so we're going to get into all kinds
of things i'm super pumped it's good to
see you new jersey in the house tampa
australia um listen three reasons though
right off the top you should create
an online course and teach your
knowledge or skill
in an online course number one it's a
growing
industry now check this out the
e-learning market
since the year 2000 has had a market
growth rate of
900 percent now check this out for every
dollar spent on e-learning
companies make back 30 in productivity
what's powerful about that is that tells
me
investing in online courses is a smart
move you know towards the end
of 2020 i bought a whole bunch of online
courses i've invested in them over the
years
and one of the reasons we also wanted to
do it by the end of the year was because
of the tax deduction for our company
investing in learning and education for
our team jordan perez
an executive assistant at think media
took us a course
on being an executive assistant um i got
some courses
on online marketing and email marketing
and copywriting
um heather torres recently bought now
she's renovating her irv she bought a
course on a particular thing she needed
to renovate in her rv
and what the stat tells us is companies
understand that for every dollar they
spend on an online course in e-learning
they make back 30 in productivity this
is true
for us as creators and entrepreneurs as
well but here's what i really want you
to see
the global e-learning market will reach
325 billion dollars by 2025.
wow and that number's going up now
because of the pandemic
so that's telling us that it's going to
be a billion dollar a day
industry by 2025. that's a massive
industry right and so um if you were to
just get a piece of that by packaging
what you know
teaching what you know packaging a skill
inside of an online course
you can see that over the next four
years this is going to be a major wave
and i believe it's the best business
model to be in
and so definitely some things to
consider we saw that the coronavirus
has been pushing more people into online
earning
uh online learning uh that e-learning
growth in canada is skyrocketing past
the global trend
khan academy uh listed here
and that self-paced e-learning market is
to observe exponential growth
between 2021 and 2025. what's the big
takeaway
this is a massively big growing industry
and something i don't want you to sleep
on
because it's my favorite business model
you can work from home package what you
know
in this self i'm not trying to suggest
that it's easy i
i'm not trying to suggest that it
doesn't take hard work i'm not trying to
suggest that there's not competition
but if there's a wave i want to surf it
come on you know
my friend jeff who actually got me into
video back when he was my youth pastor
in 2003 now lives in oceanside
and he knows about seeing waves coming
starting to paddle out and catch that
wave for me i just get tumbled in the
wave
and don't have enough upper body
strength to even consistently surf when
i go surfing with him
but he sees a wave coming he positions
himself and he begins to ride it
that's what's happening in the online
course industry
right now now secondly is this low
overhead and high margins so let's just
kind of get on the same page and talk
about a few things
what is an online course or or even a
digital product
this could be a couple things this is
people packaging their information in an
online course
or a membership site that could be
monthly like a monthly subscription
now that could also be like youtube
channel memberships
i think about ben from keto camp and fly
ride
who does custom led headlights ben does
intermittent fasting education
they they use channel memberships they
have five bucks a month and you could be
a part of exclusive information
right now digital products i think about
omar on the thick media team
he has his lightroom presets
to help you edit your photography faster
in lightroom
he sells them for twenty dollars they
install into lightroom for other
photographers
he's made thousands it's a digital
product and also even a paid challenge
maybe you've been a part of the youtube
influence challenge we've done
that is a free challenge but sometimes
what you could do
my friend pedro does a 31 day challenge
he has 31 guest speakers
it's free but if you want the recordings
it's 31
and he gives the money to charity but
it's cool because you could put all of
those
you could gather experts in a particular
industry
and just share the recordings of like a
five-day
paid challenge and then after that
you've got an online course
so so many different ways that you could
do this what's up luria good to see you
um now why digital products well here's
a couple pros and cons and the second
one the second reason
is low overhead high margins low
overhead
high margins and so a couple pros we saw
that it's a growing industry
low overhead high margins simplicity
you know when i think about different
types of businesses
if you have to open if you were going to
open a local coffee shop and a friend of
mine opened santo coffee in seattle
crazy because of the lockdown because of
getting hit you know
with uh all the stuff that happened with
the pandemic
but when he's opened up a local coffee
shop they renovated the room
right the the they had to get the
espresso machine
they had to do marketing they had to do
a lot of things which
is powerful more power to them but when
you think about
the simplicity right of
an online course you can work from home
you can
record all this stuff online you could
create you could create it almost
completely with a smartphone
and so it's a super powerful uh
business model freedom once you've
created it you can travel
sell it on auto when you're sleeping and
things like that you're not necessarily
working
a nine to five or trading your time to
money uh for money low risk
what if i make an online course and it
fails well
do you have a garage full of network
marketing powders
that you can't sell uh do you have any
hard goods that you
like you know it's low risk because even
if you test one
it's digital right so it's also low risk
you can
even if you stretch into it like my
friend who opened a coffee shop
rent lease hard goods coffee
employees so as a business model
it's super super smart and then um
scalability
once you start to start your online
course you can start simple
you can scale it over time
as you learn more marketing things like
once you have something to sell
and you have even a sales process now
you could follow the latest social media
trend or fad but begin to
have a way to monetize so you're not
just spinning your wheels on social
media now it's not to say it's all
you know butter club buttercups
rainbows and unicorns the cons are there
is high competition you might be saying
sean
and we're going to do some q a about
some of this stuff sean
there's high competition man like
there's other people that are doing my
same
online course true so you got to figure
out
how you're going to stand out remember
the world's a big place you got to
figure
out how are you going to market and get
an edge in marketing get an edge in
where you position your course
get an edge in where you position your
expertise meaning
maybe you're using clubhouse right now
maybe you've built a big following on
instagram
but maybe youtube is so there's there's
got to be ways that you stand out that
could be a challenge how do we overcome
that
the learning curve i get it and that's
what the point of this stream is is like
uh how do i how do i sell it how long
should i make it how do i structure it
what's the outline i get that
and then there's also the easy myth the
easy myth
which is the idea that some people
when they talk about online courses they
over hype it like oh it's just so easy i
just threw
it's it's not easy it is simple
and if you follow a proven path it's the
best business model but
it's not easy because of course you need
to build
like a sales page and build landing
pages and probably build an email list
and learn to connect your shopping cart
which is like stripe or paypal
there's things to do it's not i'm not
here to overwhelm
just to shoot straight with what it
takes and so
finding ways to overcome that learning
curve accelerates your education
so that you can get an edge with your
online
course the second reason though is low
overhead high margins there's so many
prawns uh pros and honestly
the pros outweigh the cons number three
is it's the best business model for
youtube creators i really believe that
the best business model for youtube
creators and if you have a question
throw four question marks at me before
and after the question
and i'd love to help about online
courses and smash like if you're getting
value
why is it the best business model for
online course creators well
because if you um even if you have a
small audience
a friend pat flynn wrote a book called
super fans and
it was partly inspired by this article
called 1000 true fans
and if you were to sell an online course
okay
for um like 57
and let's say you had five or ten
thousand youtube subscribers
but you only had about a thousand super
fans and because they're super fans
they all purchase your online course
well if you sold a 57 course
for to a thousand true fans that would
be fifty seven thousand dollars
so you don't need a million subscribers
you don't need to be
kim kardashian or dwayne the rock
johnson
you just need a small targeted audience
that loves
what you do you know i had the privilege
of doing some coaching
the other day with swavy curly courtney
and she actually has created a course
that is all about um
her helping you wash your curly hair
and so you'd be surprised by the
different things
that you can do in the different niches
that people do this in
but it's a one-hour class it's a
one-hour master class
that is 57
and people her community loves her she's
built this great channel but it's an
extra income stream now i think about
people like nicole from kids ot help
so she is a kid's occupational therapist
and sometimes when you see some of these
examples you might see them today
because they've been building for years
i mean she joined one of our online
courses years ago called video ranking
academy
and so she's over 100 000 subscribers
now she joined
maybe like 12 000 subscribers or
something maybe five
but she has built out so you go here to
her website
and uh that's how you log into your
online course members area
but you can go here and she has coaches
and coursing
transforming tummy time the reunion
foundations for feeding weaning
essentials
the new mama bundle and you can purchase
this online course it's 333 dollars for
the full bundle
i think about cassandra thompson who
does career coaching and helps people do
job interviews
and helps people uh get that next raise
or get that next
best job i think about fly ride and so
fly ride chris he helps you do custom
headlights
and he has not only built a business
selling the custom headlights he has
about 10 different income streams
but we can go over here and see that he
has online courses
where you can purchase uh on fly ride
automative lighting here and you can
solder and do the circuit boards
that's a free course so this then you've
got sequential courses fifty dollars
ninety seven dollars
he's built out lots of different courses
so let me know what's one
idea you have for a course mccain dogs
they actually have 75 employees in
canada
local dog training but they also created
an online course
for doing dog training uh ruslan uh
is does christian commentary faith bible
study things
he's working on his second course right
now and he's done a lot of music stuff i
think that's what his first course is
about
is he's helped people with monetizing as
a musician and different things that
he's done as a hip-hop artist and
and faith-based hip-hop artist so what's
an idea
for an online course that you have
um let me know in the comment section
but there's so many different ways to do
this so
a couple three points and we got that
case study i'm going to answer your
questions a lot of stuff coming up but
number one it's a growing industry
number two it's low overhead and high
margins
low overhead it doesn't cost much to
uh host it you know there's not a lot of
cost into building it
even when you consider investing in
something like thinkific or teachable
and by the way to answer the question
about that
we have thinkmediatools.com and i put
some resources in the description down
below
we use kajabi it's not necessarily the
best answer i think
depends on your budget thinkific is good
teachable is good
they're all pretty similar i mean you
might have some certain features you
need but you could build
an empire with any of them um but i
definitely would lean towards probably
thinkific or kajabi
and kajabi is going to help you scale a
little bit more that's what we we use
but you can see different options of the
various tools and software that we use
at think media
thinkmediatools.com
and uh low overhead high margins though
you know one of the ways i started
my biz making a full-time living from
home was doing youtube videos and
affiliate
marketing talking about tech so if i
recommended a 100
like kit someone purchased that light
kit through clicking the link
i make four percent so if they purchase
the 100
light kit i get four dollars now if you
do that enough times
you can make some pretty good money and
that's how i was able to build a six
figure income
initially but then i packaged what i
knew in an online course called the
video ranking academy back in 2016.
beginning of 2016 and teaching people
how i learned to rank videos and do all
that kind of stuff
if i sell a course for a hundred dollars
after stripe or paypal takes like two
percent you keep the rest the money
so you have to pay for maybe your
services you maybe pay for
whatever else your camera of course
stream yard or maybe different things
like that
but this could be a very low overhead
high margin type of business my friend
guy
has a actual tech store
it's called dve store and he sells ring
lights and imports
different lights that he sells and he
told me stories where
a shipping container is coming from
china and moisture gets in it or water
got in it
and ruined 50 of the load
they did not give him his money back it
was his risk as well as
the the shippers risk so he just lost
the hard goods
if inventory is sitting there and i'm
not trying to talk
down about e-commerce or drop shipping
but there's just so much more
risk and then lower margins oftentimes
he would sell a black magic camera let's
say a thousand dollars
eighty percent is how much black
blackmagic is keeping
first off so there's only 20 left then
there's like some shipping you play your
employees
he said his margins when i told him
amazon gave me four percent on tech he
goes i couldn't even afford that
at his store so the reason this is the
best business model
is because of low overhead high margins
and then for youtube creators this is
also one of the absolute best
models uh business models that you could
um ever do i went to social media
marketing world
march 2020 right before the pandemic
started and spoke on stage on youtube
and as i got off i talked to a couple
people from thinkific and they were just
like hey we'd love to
collab or talk and stuff and they said
you know our most successful software
users
and you know thinkific is a software
that helps you host your online course
they said are youtube creators
why is that it was because youtube
creators
uh youtube is used by people to learn
skills
for how-to content to learn hobbies to
people go with the intent of learning
something so they're already in a
mindset
one two they also get to know like and
trust you on youtube
so they're watching courtney and they're
like she's so cool
and she's helping me wash my hair and
deal with my curls and then
they're getting to know her and then
courtney's like hey i got this way to go
to a deeper level with me and then it is
more
linear i think about a while back
uh about forgetting your channel right
now this is what happens when you do a
stream
on a friday night after a long week it
will
come to me uh but i was thinking about
uh one girl that i interviewed on video
influencers
she does crocheting
and she does quilts and different
quilted pillow things and things like
that
and like we'll we'll sell you like a 25
thing to help you
online course to help you make a
particular crocheted blanket or pillow
and because her youtube channel is where
people meet her get to know her
learn some stuff you can have more
premium products or things that you can
ultimately help people
with and so uh super cool and powerful
business model smash like let me answer
a couple questions and then we'll get
into part two
of today's training uh unbox warehouse
says hey buddy can't wait to listen to
your hive podcast i really enjoy being
on here
thanks so much for the super chat
appreciate you
and um let's answer a couple
cues uh okay how would you go
to market your course to the world i'll
answer that in just a second
today's video actually is brought to you
it's up for a few more days if you want
to learn a little bit more about this
um and watch the free class i did we're
going to answer as many questions as we
can
but i do have a free class that's out
through the weekend
depending on which when you're watching
this at fulltimeinfluencer.com
if you're curious about the full story
where i
uh really did everything in regards to
2015 i lose my freelance clients
i was freelancing full-time went all in
on my youtube channel
focusing on youtube and affiliate
marketing and then
after i got some momentum i built an
online course i made a ton of mistakes
and
like my first web i tell the whole story
it's anyways it's at a full-time
influencer if you're curious and want
some more
uh tips on how excuse me to market your
online
course so definitely check uh that out
and uh
coming up in a second with this case
study i actually have an interview that
i recorded that i just we only shared
with our inner circle program that i'll
play for you here
that's going to help you with price
strategy
positioning it's really really cool uh
let's see diego
what do you think are the best ways to
promote a beginner's course if you're
following on all platforms is small 1k
on youtube youtube subs 1k and email
and 1.2 000 on instagram
i think you're under um
worrying about your audience being small
those are huge numbers
you know you might not you're probably
gonna one
industry numbers are like one to two
percent of
usually exposure to a particular offer
meaning
if you send an email to your 1000 email
subscribers
probably not definitely not everyone's
going to open it but
let's just say that all a thousand
opened it probably ten percent
would maybe go check out and be
interested and i believe diego you do a
lot of music and guitar right
and it's been cool hanging out and
collaborating over the years in various
places
um and music training but of the 10
100 people that look at something one
percent or two percent
would probably purchase that product and
it's a key
thing to know too is that not everybody
a lot of people might be interested in
what you have but not interested in it
right now
so one of the powerful things about
creating content online and adding value
and continue to show up week after week
is not everyone's ready to make a buying
decision my wife and i
are eventually going to need a car
because we're going to be spending more
time
up in washington state now that we have
a five-month-old named sean bradley
and we want him to be around all my
family and her family live up in
washington state
and so we are now thinking what car do
we get
so we are thinking about making a buying
decision but we're doing all kinds of
research for months
so all that to say is that that's also
the power of having an email list
because chances are if you did a
promotion to your email list just said
hey
i said what i have this is what it will
do for you this is how much it costs go
check it out
10 to 20 people will buy it out of those
a thousand if you if you also do the
things right and like
a lot of things email subject line
clarity
marketing and just really communicate
the value and think about some of those
powerful things
but then though
some people aren't ready to buy the car
yet some people be ready two weeks later
a month later
and i think that's important to know
it's never that you share something
online
one time and that's the mistake people
make they share like one time they're
like only island sold one course or you
can
you got to continue talking about it
people are buying cars today
next week and six months from now so
like they're always making different
buying decisions
so the powerful thing about social media
is you can keep adding value
keep connecting keep giving out free
content and doing a lot of things like
that
but those are great numbers you do the
same principles at the numbers you're at
as well as bigger numbers
so um i hope that adds value smash like
if you are getting some value and
today's
uh video is brought to you by our free
class open up for a few more days
fulltimeinfluencer.com check that out
link in the description down below but
as we go into part two here
um buckle your seat belt because a
friend of mine brock
johnson uh shared with me
and actually our inner circle community
of how he
came up with his name first course
priced it built it to six figures
while playing college football and
having to juggle college classes
so if you think this has to take all of
your time if you think
that um you know this is not practical
you're going to love this next
portion so reset grab something to write
with this is so
dense with information that i think is
going to help you
in a lot of different uh questions and
things that you may have
and um this is a pre-recorded video that
we just shared with our inner circle
community but i just kind of wanted
i thought it was just so valuable that i
wanted to share with you as well
and then i'll be back for more q a in
just a second
inner circle sean cannell here and i'm
fired up for this bonus
session with brock johnson and we're
going to just be talking about all
things
online courses packaging what you know
and
selling it and serving people by helping
solve
a problem brock johnson um today is
running with chalene johnson
insta clubhub a massive kind of
membership site helping people crush
with instagram
um he helps entrepreneurs and content
creators with instagram
and he's helped thousands grow their
brands get their confidence going
and really reach more people with ig
but what's really crazy is that while in
college playing college football
he built a six-figure business by
packaging what he knows into an online
course he created a couple different
mini courses
and so we're going to talk about all
things lead magnets aka freemiums
uh hosting your course uh lessons he
learned mistakes he made
email lists he built where the sales
come from how he did pricing
and just kind of break down some real
tactical uh stuff so brock johnson
thanks so much for uh
coming on today yeah sean of course
thanks for having me
so bro um for those that don't know uh
we go back a while now
our best moments or when we're
snowboarding and uh
and i love your mission
uh you're recently engaged with which is
congratulations
um and you um are just an incredible
human being
uh but it's so remarkable that at 23
years old now
doing this for four years while in
high school really and then into college
uh really in college right like when
you're 19 you started to kind of get
into this stuff
uh in a full time doing this full time
so you're doing it before
um and you created a couple things so if
you could just break down your story i
want to get tactically into the details
but kind of explain
how your business started and kind of
when you created your first course and
kind of what was happening in your life
at the time
um go for it heck yes all right let's do
it uh so my
freshman year of college i will walk you
through how that all went
i was going to school across the country
in washington dc and my family is
originally from southern california
and so at that time uh the only real way
to communicate with my family on a daily
basis and stay
in the loop uh was through text
messaging pictures back and forth which
just got really
overwhelming and cumbersome and honestly
kind of annoying to be getting pictures
all day from my mom and dad
so i was like hey why don't we use
snapchat instead and i taught them how
to use snapchat i taught them like
here's all the buttons here's how it's
laid out this is how you use snapchat
fast forward a few weeks later my mom
came to visit me and i expressed her
that i was feeling this kind of guilt
or overwhelm because i have been living
on my own for a few weeks but
very heavily relying on them they had
given me a credit card when i went off
to college and i was using that for
groceries and food and
pretty much all my living expenses i
didn't really have like a savings
account to rely on and
i was a college football player so i
didn't really have time to get like a
traditional job
because i just couldn't work those hours
so i told my mom that she's like all
right
let's create a business for you let's
create a way
that you can earn an income for yourself
with your expertise
and you can provide for yourself while
in college without having to have that
job working all those hours
so we brainstormed for a little bit and
now this will tie back into where this
plane took off from where this
conversation started which was
teaching parents how to use snapchat
that was my very first course that i
ever made
it was teaching parents how to keep
their kids safe on snapchat teaching
them
the ins and outs of how to use all the
different buttons you know telling them
about
different hidden features that they
might not know about and how to really
protect their kids and
have the necessary conversations again
what did i know about parenting not very
much i was only 19 years old but
i knew how to teach them how to use
snapchat and i knew that if i could at
least get them over that hump
we could make big progress towards
helping keep kids safe on
snapchat so i actually recorded that
entire course
it's hilarious to look back on it i
recorded it in
a room at the georgetown library in just
some random room on
one of the basement floors i snuck into
one of the rooms
i didn't have a ring light i had no
professional lighting i didn't even have
a tripod
most of my early videos in that course
um
were shot shooting like up my nose
terrible angle
no microphone and it's really funny to
look back on
but i cranked out those videos in a week
and a few months later i launched that
course
for 19 was my initial offer wow that's
amazing and so
what year is this this was 2016
2016 and what was the course called it
was called
unwrap snap unwrap snap and it ended up
being like how long
how many videos you think it ended up
being a really built out course and i
ended up upping the price at the time of
launch it was around 20 to 25
videos that were all about five minutes
in length or so
um and by the by the time i kind of
stopped promoting the course and stopped
working on it it
ended up around 60 lessons okay that's a
really cool and teach on that for a
second so
you you launch it with 25 videos you get
it done you shoot it in a week you sneak
into a room
you shoot it with just the phone that
you have yeah where'd you host it
i hosted it on kajabi so you host it on
kajabi
and you sell it for 19 at first but once
it grew up to 60
60 lessons what price did you go to next
i tested out a few different prices
which i think is very important is you
know
seeing how your audience responds to
different price points i think it got as
high as 57
uh but the settling price that i kind of
stuck with was i believe
37 for that course and it really grew
and evolved based on feedback
from the the customers who did purchase
it from the parents who did purchase it
who would say you know
uh this is great but what about this or
i'm struggling with this
or maybe snapchat would release a new
feature and
and i would have to create a lesson
explaining how that works
um so that's kind of how it grew and
evolved and it was really over a year or
so
that that course continued to be really
a living and breathing thing that was
evolving and changing
so cool and here that inner circle it
grew and evolved
he shot it he put it out there it was
missing things
because it wasn't until he got feedback
that there was more things to add but he
was able to get it out
for a lower lower price raise the price
later
brock it's inspiring because it's like
like
what price i don't know test one will
all the
answers be there no get the course out
there um
you know will it be perfect absolutely
not i'll be shooting videos up my nose
uh i can get mics later i can improve
the quality later and i want you to hear
i love that
bro cause the massive action you took to
um to get people engaging in that super
super powerful
and by the way inner circle if you
didn't listen to our think marketing
podcast episode where
brock shared his eight tips on building
your confidence that's kind of a huge
piece of it because brock
you really did just punch fear in the
face yeah start were you nervous were
you afraid that it wasn't gonna be right
were you like uh
am i gonna let people down or what were
your thoughts yeah so i was
nervous as heck to be around any of my
friends or any of my fellow college
football players and tell them what i
was doing
um i definitely didn't post about it at
all on my own social media
that's why that's big part of the reason
why i snuck into a room in the basement
of the georgetown library is because i
didn't want to be doing this out in
public or to tell my friends what i was
doing because i knew that
you know maybe a lot of them would laugh
at me especially considering this was
something i hadn't really talked about
and something that they didn't know
as part of who i was um and you know i
was a freshman in college
in a new place across the country so
there was already a lot of
barriers to my confidence there but i
you know like we talked about in that
podcast episode i remembered my why
and i knew that i wanted to create that
financial freedom and that was really
what drove me
so i was like let you know i'm going to
crank it out i had a deadline
i had a week basically before we started
football season to get these videos
recorded
and so i grinded like i sat in that room
all day long
i brought like couple bags of almonds
and just kept snacking on almonds and
recording
all day and i and i busted it out man
that's so cool so then how did you
how did you drive sales build your email
list was there a free download first did
it's lower ticket so did you just sell
it directly uh how did sales work
yeah so sales i i will not lie didn't
have an email list necessarily when i
launched
i had some social media followers but
not a ton maybe only about three or four
thousand on instagram at that point
um and i've been on instagram for a long
time so it kind of naturally
grown and it wasn't a audience that was
primarily
filled with who my ideal customer was at
that time
most of my followers were other high
school and college football players
it wasn't the parents who i was looking
to sell to um so i didn't necessarily
have an email list i didn't have a
freemium or an
opt-in i did and i'm very transparent
with this i did rely on my mom to
she posted once to her audience um about
it
and i did rely on a lot of the other
moms who i got in
early that was one thing that i did for
sure is any time
in that initial offer phase especially
in the first few days after release
that somebody did join i would
personally reach out to them
and really build that relationship and
that connection and what that did
was that created a opportunity for those
moms to then
promote me themselves and to start
sharing within their mom groups and on
facebook and on their social medias
and that was very word of mouth how it
grew yeah that's strong and
and of course uh if chalene johnson
shouts you out that's a powerful thing
um but you unlocked a huge strategy
there
because you get a first initial
customers meanwhile you also are
solving an incredible pain point not
just teaching parents about
snapchat but when you even think about
marketing levers
you know we never play on things to
manufacture emotions
but there's a real fear there yeah fear
is one of the best drivers of marketing
fear of what are my kids doing how do i
know what my kids are doing
like what are the dangers here and so
and 19 bucks that's
like a low friction sale so of a mom
is learning and getting results and
would share that with her community
and uh and spread the word then
it all starts one sale at a time one
customer at a time yeah
exactly what um what were the sales
once you close down that program yeah i
think i ended up around a thousand
customers or so
uh in that and that was over like a year
and a half period that we got to that
that number um very quickly though by
the end of the first year
um was when that course started to
transition into my next course
um and my next course i think was again
i tested the price as high
as 97 as low as 27 ended up at the sweet
spot of 57
and that was again listening to my
audience listening to my customers and
adapting as i learned from them and
basically here's what happened sean
i taught dozens of parents especially
moms
how to use snapchat this is an entire
market now
an entire group of people who has
learned from me who is on this new
social media
and they were saying things to me like
brock i grow on facebook i use facebook
for business
i use youtube for business i use my
instagram for business
but snapchat like i want to use it for
business and i have a business i'm a
business owner
can you teach me and i very much felt
qualified to do so
because over the last year where i had
been promoting this course and teaching
on snapchat
i had also been using my own snapchat as
a way to communicate with all my
customers on a daily basis so
that was my main social media platform
at that time
and so i was getting a couple thousand
views on every single snapchat story
and from that i was like heck i was able
to grow my business on snapchat
i now have taught thousands of
entrepreneurs
thousands of parents who own businesses
how to use snapchat
i should also teach them how to grow
their business like i did using snapchat
and what was that course called that was
uh unreal
that was unwrapped snap for business so
it was just kind of like the four
business
was added on there um and then that did
eventually change
too uh to what was called unwrapped
stories
to also include instagram stories
wow so i mean there's so many lessons
here
one the evolution of uh
even your course i mean that's three
major kind of evolutions
as platforms and social media are
evolving i think another massive unlock
there that inner circle i want you to
hear is
way too many people focus on making
sales
when the key to business of any kind
is creating customers um
a sale is what potential potential
potentially one-time event
whereas a customer is a potential could
lead to
10 20 life-long numbers
of sales think about it what's your
favorite clothing brand if you have one
that you shop online
or go to a store what's your where do
you drink coffee if you're on a road
trip do you stop at starbucks
starbucks didn't just make a sale from
me starbucks has literally made
thousands of dollars from me
if they evolved their product lines and
have a new offering
i just might check that out if i think
about some of my favorite authors
um they haven't just michael hyatt i
haven't just bought one of his books
i now have probably bought all of his
books a new book
gary vaynerchuk comes out and then i
purchase a
fifth or sixth sale could be more
courses more
services more things and so part of it
is just getting started because once you
have a base of customers
like you mentioned you had about a
thousand customers and then you started
evolving things
uh maybe not everyone wants to go to the
next step but now you have a chance to
invite them into unwrapped staff for
business or unwrap staff
for stories um any thoughts on that yeah
absolutely so i think that um in looking
at my own customers
the average customer of mine usually has
at least two products and i also have
services and other things now and they
have at least
three uh things you say three products
or and or services
from me and that's that's a huge point
that you made there is
so many of the the people who joined
unwrap snap way back in the day in 2016
um they have evolved they've changed
since then but so has what i've offered
so has what i've taught on and i've been
able to pivot and change and evolve and
grow with them
and so that's kept them in my customer
base and that's kept them
coming back and now after four or five
years of learning from me they very much
understand how i teach they trust me
they know like and trust me
um and so when i release an instagram
membership or release a
a new course or a new service or product
or offering
the the necessity to really have to
convince them to trust me
or to do a great job writing sales copy
isn't as
needed because my audience knows me
already man that's
brilliant so sales numbers when did you
hit six figures
playing back uh football and where
where'd the money come from
yeah that was the the end of my
sophomore year
uh so that year that was uh so it would
be
2018. okay mid 2018
so so the end of my sophomore year two
years after you created your first
course
also very insightful friends you know i
guess online you're like okay
oh wow so like high school uh college
football player
makes six figures you're like what like
he did that in a week you know you just
think like it's a headline it's like
but but there's so much grind and so
much
phones being filmed up the nose and
downs shooting in basements
and like and mistakes along the way so
there's a whole two years
as we start as you hit certain sales
figures carry on and uh
kind of how did all was it from a couple
different courses by that time
yeah so by that time it was a couple
different courses i had
the unwrap snap which had transitioned
into unwrapped stories to really talk
about
not just snapchat stories and snapchat
for business but also
starting to use instagram and instagram
stories for business because
instagram stories was a direct copy of
snapchat stories that's where they got
the idea from
that plus a secondary course uh which
was very very specific and i think that
that's
another key point here is that my second
uh kind of
course that i created was called help
with hashtags
and it solved a very specific problem it
wasn't a how to use instagram course
it wasn't instagram marketing it wasn't
grow your business it wasn't even
you know best posting strategies it was
just
all about instagram hashtags and
teaching you a very specific strategy
that i had created myself
and that i had my own expertise in and
so just that one very specific thing was
something i was able to
really grow and that's actually to this
day my most successful course
is help with hashtags i think there's
over 3 000 members
um who ended up purchasing help with
hashtags and then also at the end of
my sophomore year was my first time ever
introducing
direct consultation so i started to
offer one-on-one coaching
a big learning lesson there that we can
we can talk about in a minute if you
want was i really underpriced myself
would you praise yourself at first i was
my intro rate was eighty seven dollars
for an hour
um and then people could buy packages
where it was uh you could buy a five
call or a ten call package
which would make it even less i think it
got as low as something like fifty
dollars an hour
um but with how many customers i had and
a couple thousand people
inside help with hashtags and inside
unwrapped stories
and only having really about an hour a
day of free time between classes school
football and all that
um i could only really take on about
five clients so that's what i mean by
under pricing myself is uh very quickly
i had to shut that down because i got
more than five clients and i was like
i'm not gonna have time to work with
everyone
and how much was uh hope with hashtags
help with hashtags was 57 as well
so i mean that alone is 171 000
if it's a 57 course and 3 000 students
is that accurate yeah that's about what
it was yep and uh
and so the one other just a couple
things as we land the plane obviously
this is like a
massive crash course and a lot of data
inner circle i want to give you a couple
challenges number one
um what do you need to do next inner
circle because
of course uh i love that it was brick by
brick it was piece by piece again you
could see
171 thousand dollars but there was a
process that went into this clarity went
into this
brock took strategic action at first but
he refined his plan
as he went at some point as
entrepreneurs it sometimes is
uh you know ready fire aim you know you
get ready
you fire and then you start to aim like
as you're like all right cool
but it is get ready first and he
launched with clarity he launched in a
niche he launched with snapchat what he
knew
he started to refine it i love that she
got even more clarity
on your second course and you understood
more things about the market and the
power of having a really specific thing
so inner circle
what's your first smaller course it
doesn't have to be an academy
his first course was 25 videos and it
was 19
when he launched it out and of course we
talked about baby offers which
you know at some point you're gonna see
brock inside uh
for those that if you've heard about
marketing impact academy
and if you've been following any of some
of the resources we've been sending of
course brock's there i'm in there
talking about youtube chalene johnson
and this kind of stuff like really at
the deepest level of the baby offer and
the freemium and the pricing
and the k and researching uh focus
groups
and your sales video and sales video
messaging
brick by brick piece by piece that's all
inside of the marketing impact academy
but brooke uh as we land the plane
actually
you should have priced yourself higher
on the 101 you got a bunch of courses
you're hitting six figures 2018
in playing college football lastly i
know it's a big topic
but you also built out a team because
people might be like well dude how's he
doing this
you had a couple of virtual assistants
you had a couple a couple people that
you installed what was
what what did it take to run your
business when you were
2018 running unwrapped stories help with
hashtags and maybe a little bit of how
you ramped in because you didn't just go
from zero to there
so how did you build your team up as you
went to manage this
absolutely so i say to this day the best
investment i ever made was hiring my
virtual assistant
i hired her in 2017 and the biggest
spike in my business up until that point
was right after i hired her
literally a direct correlation the week
that i hired her
was the best week i had ever done that
week surpassed the entire 51 weeks prior
and here's why after i hired my virtual
assistant i was able to take
the majority of things off my plate
editing
scheduling repurposing she was able to
do
research for me and find relevant
articles and and new
uh features on snapchat she helped me
immensely
what i tangibly did that week is i went
live for an
hour a day inside uh the facebook group
community that i had created around that
first course
and i ended up keep doing that i kept
doing it for for an entire month so for
30 days straight i went live for an hour
a day
and it was in the the corner of a hotel
room where i was staying a lot of the
times it was in my dorm room
but i was able to pour into my audience
that much more
because i had hired my first virtual
assistant to help me out with other
things
and i i guess you know part of it is
luck that i happen to hire
the the best virtual assistant ever here
five years later
she's still working with us she's
actually been hired by team johnson to
now
uh work with us full-time she's awesome
like i text with her on a daily basis
um but i will say to this day the best
investment i ever made was hiring that
first virtual assistant and then since
then
um when i first launched my first
podcast i hired a podcast editor
uh when i first you know started doing
that second course the help with
hashtags course
i hired an editor to edit all my videos
for me so i started to learn
what it was like to hire help and to
ask for help as an entrepreneur because
often times you know we have this idea
that
i got to do it all myself or i'll save
money if i do it myself
but what you don't realize is sure you
might not be paying someone
a couple hundred bucks to edit those
videos for you but you're gonna spend
way more time editing them yourself and
that's time that you lose out on on your
own expertise doing what you love and
what you're best at your own zone of
genius
so i think that that one of the biggest
lessons that i learned
early on in entrepreneurship that i that
i wish everyone knew
was the the value and the power in
outsourcing
asking for help and hiring help man we
let me know inner circle if you want to
have brock johnson come for one of our
official monthly sessions
and what topics you'd like to have him
expand on because that was some serious
fire
and um you know what i love about that
too
is like you mentioned you got lucky it
was awesome that you found your first
hire
sometimes you have to kiss a few frogs
before you find your prince
but i like what you said it's it's
inevitable that you're gonna have to
build your team inner circle i want to
remind you
we've got our 10 steps in inner circle
the first five number one claim and
master your topic
number two discover your audience's
problems and ambitions number three
post at least one significant post a
week and of course depending on what
platform we're talking about youtube
if you're in brock's world doing ig you
better be posting more than once a week
but you're posting significant content
that is going to build your business
number four what's the shortest path to
revenue get that mini offer done get
that
baby offer done get that unwrapped snap
course done for 19
and get that revenue flowing number five
get help get help and start and start
and and get help sometimes before you
think you need it definitely before you
think you need it before you think
you're ready
get help and be smart about reinvesting
your dollars back into your business
back into people because that's
really the only lever to scale and
you're going to find yourself
exhausted if you keep looping for uh
through the first four steps
without scaling up it's super scary it's
nerve-wracking
and the scary part is you're like i
might make a mistake i might pay someone
for a couple weeks or months
and they might not turn out to be right
there might be some drama there probably
will be
for most people but um it is part of the
business the definition of entrepreneur
is somebody who starts and builds
a business with extraordinary financial
risk risk there's no risk
there's no risk if you just stay at home
and you don't try something but if you
want to
uh really build something significant
you at some point got to get
uncomfortable of course do it smart
and one of my favorite programs that you
guys also have is virtual business
academy as well because
it's it even breaks that down in greater
detail
but uh at the end of the day such
inspiring story brock
and i just i'm curious what
uh your final kind of word of advice
for the person who's like man you guys
throw out a bunch of numbers
uh maybe i've even i'm kind of doing my
course there's just so much stuff
to do what what what helped you stay
focused stay disciplined and just get
through
this process of building up your online
business specifically packaging what you
know into an online course and different
membership sites and stuff
what is your advice for people at every
stage in this journey
yeah i think that um and we've talked
about this before
it's really remembering your why um i
think
part of the story part of my story that
we didn't talk about in here
uh is right after i reached that six
figure mark
i actually took six months off of
business and off of social media
didn't do any sales and do any podcasts
no live streaming
not even a single post on social media i
signed off and deleted them all off my
phone
because i recognized that that was the
season of life i was in at that time i
was
going into my junior year of college and
i was playing college football
and i wanted to soak it in i wanted to
be a college student and experience all
that that
was involved and i knew that my career
would end one day
as everyone's football career eventually
does um
and so i took time off that off my
business and
absolutely my business did not do as
well in those six months as it did in
the six months prior
absolutely i probably could have gained
a lot more followers if i stayed on
social media
during those few months but i made the
conscious decision
to honor my priorities and to honor my
why
and to really honor the season of life
that i was in so i think that
seasons of life are important whether
you just got engaged or you just had
your first kid
or your kids just left for college or
you are
in a grind phase because you're a solo
entrepreneur
and you're single and you're just trying
to grow your business
and grow your social media channels i
think it's important to
to know the season that you're in honor
the season that you're in
and keep your why at the front of your
mind so for me
one of my wives has absolutely been to
help others and to serve others and to
you know really share as much value and
give away as much as i can
but during that season of my life my why
my driving purpose was i wanted to be
present i wanted to be
there and i wanted to soak it all up um
and so i
put myself first and put my business
bottom line and my social media
followers
uh second for that time in my life whoo
seasons and that is the power of friends
that's the power of creating these types
of business this is the
most highly leveraged impact driven but
also lifestyle style driven types of
businesses creating something you can
create once but sell multiple times
creating automation
um and not being able to just serve and
impact people and help people
but also take six months off which is
super inspiring and such a target for so
many of us
brock johnson if you look on the screen
right there at
brock 11 johnson that's your ig that is
that's everything handle
brock 11 what's the meaning of the 11
man your whole family you got tattoos
yeah you guys your sister's got the
tattoo 11
brock 11 johnson what's the 11 yeah the
11's the
it's a family number grandpa is the
second winningest high school football
coach in the state of california history
um he played high school in college my
dad
and uncle played high school college pro
i played high school college
our entire family has always been number
11. it's a very
uh athletic family and a very sports
driven family and 11's always been our
number there's also 11 johnson's in the
family
um and so 11 is just a very special
number and now
um all of us in our immediate family
have that tattoo and
even my grandma wants to get the 11
tattoo she said
man that's awesome and uh brock 11
johnson hit him up on instagram he's
super helpful dm him
um and i'm gonna try to convince him to
come into inner circle sometime this
year to go deeper
on some of this uh stuff brock thank you
so
much sean thank you for having me
let me know what one of your takeaways
was from that that was
that was sean a few weeks ago talking to
brock without a beard now the beard is
here
smash like for the beard let's vote uh
shave it
keep it grow it longer build out the
viking beard
uh my wife sonia likes it so i mean
that's probably that's probably the
direction i'm gonna keep it going
because
you know you gotta got a happy wife
happy life as they say hey uh let me
know your biggest aha moment for that
we've got a few more things coming up
and i want to answer
your questions if you've got a question
or you learned something powerful
uh from that then um put four questions
mark
marks before and after your question
heather says happy wife happy life could
it be more true
and daelon says get the viking beard it
might it doesn't grow that thick
but but isaiah taurus which is heather
taurus husband
he's going to give me some beard oil
that's like some miracle girl i'm going
to see what i can do and try to get this
thing going
like some god of war ps5 stuff going on
you know what i'm saying keep the beard
i like the votes man we're into that and
uh
as renika says uh or ren
am i saying your name right rencia
jackson hey well
wife matters most she well she's like i
don't like it but like well wifey
matters most you might want to stick
with that
um listen i want to drop some of your
questions about online courses let me
know your aha moments
from that training and there's this is
only available for a few more days but
we have a free web class
um learn how to create sell and launch
an online course in 2021
it's a free web class uh one hour
and i break down a lot more information
i know we can't cover everything here
so definitely rsvp or register for that
there's a link in the description down
below
or check it out in the facebook comments
or just type in that your url
full time influencer
dot com and then at the end of that web
class i also let you know
about a really special bundle we are
doing it's our youtube growth bundle
that is paired with um brock onsen
is a part of an academy with chalene
johnson called the marketing
impact academy and so a lot of we've
been getting a lot of questions about it
and whatnot the best thing to do
if you have any questions about that is
just go to mia
bonus dot com and if you're really
serious
about wanting to package promote and
launch an online course and get all the
steps
all in one place i won't even really go
into the details
uh because there's just a lot but just
go to miabonus.com or you can check a
link in the description down below
you'll see a video from me there's kind
of a countdown timer depending on when
you're watching this for
when everything expires and besides that
step-by-step program
we've put together a couple things our
camera confidence course our youtube
strategy workshop
my personal branding master class and if
you know heather taurus on the think
media team we are also doing a two hour
like coaching session with us on zoom
that'll be very intimate and personal
where we can review your stuff
and a couple other cool things so if
you've got questions about that
mi a bonus.com is where
all of that information is um
the cor the question uh can you type
your pronunciation
of your name ren sia renee sia um
i'm really wanting to nail it and make
sure i say it right
i'm building a community in spo
testimonial channel
looking for ways to make a digital
product around it really great question
and i would say this you know success
leaves clues and you don't necessarily
want to just
make up an online course you want to
prove your online course idea
and i'm going to give you a secret right
now on how to
do that one of the best things you could
do is go to udemy
and see if if your niche your idea
has an online course that is selling now
udemy is a place where you can host your
online course
for free they take a cut or they take
you're not actually able to communicate
with your people
i don't really recommend it but i do
recommend it for research and here's
what i mean
let's say you were to type in something
like guitar guess what
of course there's going to be online
courses on guitar
but it gives you kind of an idea okay
what's out there
electric guitar for beginners and what's
crazy
is you can even start like really doing
some math
on people that are creating online
courses so if this course
is 60 59.99 and there's 645 students in
it
then we know that this course has
generated 38
700 so of course people are looking for
guitar
but i saw somebody else asking earlier
about language
you know you might look at something
like home decor and
you can go to udemy.com do some research
just because your niche is not on here
doesn't mean necessarily that you should
or shouldn't do that course idea
but success leaves clues chances are if
there's people interested in feng shui
um people that are interested in the
home decor
course or how to make lamp shades this
becomes really interesting to me
because how to make lampshades you go
well
what kind of online course is that could
that be profitable well let's see
1999. there's 540 students
and this has generated 10 794 dollars
you see how i'm doing that i'm kind of
just doing some market research
and so you know i think that there's so
many different things now if you were to
type in language
of course a lot of people maybe want to
learn a certain language okay
programming languages
nlp natural language processing with
python that's also i think programming
but also the complete english language
course
in um improv
spoken english 66 000 students
like what are we talking about my
friends this is
a massive growing industry and this is
why i'm encouraging you to get in
let's just do the math on this and so
this course has generated 3.9 million
dollars specifically three
million nine hundred and sixty four
thousand four hundred and thirty nine
dollars
and so that's that's pretty good i mean
it's kind of crazy like that you could
see
there's a long tail anywhere from a
couple extra thousand to
to lots of of dollars but here's the big
key
you want to make sure you're creating a
course in the right niche um
and you don't want to get romantic i
like to say about
what you'd be creating your course about
like you want to go
in to it uh and
re-ni sia renisia
i hope that answers your question so
verify your course idea i'm not sure
if that would be the best course idea
but i want to encourage you
that you can
use that process to kind of test your
idea and it might steer you towards a
different online course idea
hey sean is the master class for the
video ranking
community uh is your question like are
you already in video ranking academy
we actually have a free master class
that eventually leads to our online
course
but that is not full-time influencer
again what i normally talk about right
is youtube what i normally our main
online courses on youtube
i believe youtube is the best traffic
source for uh getting
awareness getting discovered but
eventually
the the iceberg underneath potentially
youtube youtube views affiliate
marketing
i believe is packaging what you need
what you know and a skill in an online
course
so that's what full-time influencer is
about we don't talk
necessarily a lot about online courses
mostly probably what you
follow me here on facebook or youtube
for right is youtube tips
youtube advice but this is kind of the
behind the scenes
of what we uh do one of the things that
we do
in fact i wanted to show you and i've
never shared this with
anybody before actually don't tell mel
or heather
um i one of the reasons i'm so
passionate about this
is it's kind of maybe you're a part of
one of our online courses maybe you've
um you know seen a couple things we have
now made a
ton of online courses this is our kajabi
so mind you
we've launched things at different times
but we've got
strategy workshops the old version of
video ranking academy our inner circle
start your podcast youtube hyper growth
and i'm youtube behind the scenes 10x
your brand
video impact some stuff that's not
available anymore
crush collabs business accelerator
sessions circular so i've done this a
lot like i haven't talked about it a ton
but like we've done a lot of different
online courses
that's the power of having
uh tools uh like kajabi and so again
you can use think ethic you could use
teachable and and i'm not suggesting you
get overwhelmed
i've been doing this for five years and
i've been doing this now with the think
media team i've been doing this with
heather taurus
who's the online course queen in terms
of marketing and packaging
melissa caputo is helping us but we also
launched following a method that was
taught to us
from chalene johnson and that's brock
johnson's mom
so anyways couple things practically and
i'll take a couple more questions
if you're curious about tools man where
i host my course
eventually you can answer a lot of
different questions
you can start with 101 201 301 you could
do all kinds of different things
not some of those were experiments and
they didn't work super well
others have been amazing and so i've
made a lot of mistakes
and one of the reasons i'm sharing all
this with you right now is because once
a year
chalene johnson opens up the door to the
course that changed my life and that's
called the marketing impact academy and
so besides all this free training i just
wanted you to also know about
miabonus.com and whatnot because it's
helpful to follow a proven path
follow somebody who's done it before and
someone that can help you go from a to z
nail your niche figure out the exact
person you serve the exact problem
and everything all the way through the
whole process and again
a little more details about that at mia
bonus.com
do you think a membership program can be
as scalable as an online course
that's a great question you know
membership programs are the best
possible business model because it's mrr
there's a marketing term for you very
important term
for businesses that are being evaluated
businesses that when you when you think
about what the real value of your
business is
here's what it means monthly recurring
revenue
so you can continue to sell your online
course but
mrr is monthly recurring revenue why is
netflix valuable
monthly reoccurring revenue members who
keep watching they keep creating new
content but they want to retain members
why is amazon prime
valuable monthly recurring revenue
that's the power of a membership program
online course so arguably both are
scalable but
i would argue a membership program is
more scalable both come with different
challenges
and um those are some things to consider
but mrr
is is the power of
of a membership site and
this is what i'd recommend though i
wouldn't start with a membership program
because now you're starting to commit to
something monthly that you have to keep
updated
i would start with a a mini course
something simple we mentioned early and
if you're just joining check out the
replay
we mentioned uh courtney's 57
one hour curly hair course start with
something don't
one of the mistakes i made was i built
an academy when i started
and a cat like seven modules today
it's like a workbook you know
it's like all these it's like a lot of
stuff
which is awesome but it's very
overwhelming to start that way start
simple and
scale as you go and i would not
recommend starting with a membership
program just because that could be
a lot hey hit like if you've been
getting value out of
this uh training today if you haven't
dropped one of your aha moments yet let
me know one of your aha moments
and uh would love to uh connect more
there's
links if you happen to be watching this
on youtube on the think marketing
channel
resources down below that can help you
out and
let me check out this question here hey
i'm an audiologist
and a speech language pathologist could
i make a course explaining how to
resolve
your kids articulation disorders or
stuttering disorders
or may a course for both adults and kids
separately
like how we do in our therapy sessions
well a kid is probably not going
a kid is not going to buy the course
they don't have a credit card
and they're probably not going to
discover your content so number one i
would say you're going to market to a
doc
a adults number two let's do the test
let's look up stuttering disorders and
just see if there's anybody
that is making content related to that
so no so that doesn't mean here's
stuttering mastery
and it's only got eight students not
bad it's only 1.5 hours keep that in
mind
and this maybe could be marketed so so
this is a mini course right
one downloadable resource one article
1.5 hours
35 bucks eight students now that's also
great
as a starting point and can keep being
sold keep being updated
and you could teach your methodology to
help with study
stuttering the other thing that you
should just do is just google just go
stuttering online course
you actually listen want competition
okay because
it sounds funny but
speech again so so this is good stuff
this is looking at
okay this is like speech a trial monthly
you might even want to sign up for some
of this stuff like check it out do
do the one week trial what are they
teaching now you have your own
methodology
but what you're looking for the hu the
biggest mistake people make
is they're afraid of
uh you know competition
when competition should encourage you
for example let me ask you a question
number one
full participation tell me in the
comments do you read books or listen to
audiobooks
full participation yes or no do you read
books
do you um any kind fiction
teen fiction leadership faith
novels memoirs do you read
books question number one i read books
sony and i between us have about 2 000
books in
our house so heather says
yes i read books bill reads yes
awesome okay so question for heather and
bill and everybody
have you ever bought your driver mic
audiobooks only
have you only bought one book in your
life on one particular topic
a lot of people saying yes uh or have
you bought more than one
leadership book have you bought more
than one
fiction book have you ever have you only
ever read one book on a topic and then
like i've covered leadership forever or
business forever or entrepreneurship
forever or did you buy
more than one book on a particular topic
let me know
if you've done you know more than just
one copy
uh and so for me
i mean i kind of have a problem but like
i
i have hundreds of books on
entrepreneurship
hundreds of books on leadership hundreds
of books on christianity in faith
and different aspects of whether it's
prayer
whether it's church leadership as that's
part of my background
and so heather's actually wrote a book
so and have you wrote a book like that'd
be the next question
but so tony's summing it up right here
yes i've bought
i've bought multiple books on a topic so
a couple things a lot of people
take more than one course and so what
i'm suggesting is
if you do the research and like no one
has created the idea
yet and there's not competition like if
someone is sold if there's a leadership
book on amazon that has 10 000 reviews
you go that's good news it's not like oh
they're the only one
i can write a leadership book and i
might get 100 reviews or 10
and however many sales but it's proof
that people care about the particular
niche this is called
uh like market vari verification or
determining market via
viability kind of talking about some
fancy marketing stuff
and so as we land the plane on that i
encourage you
definitely watch full-time influencer if
you have more questions about
uh about that about starting online
course
and i hope that proves uh the point
though we have a lot of people
i have a lot of books uh and then
tons of books and audiobooks on similar
topics of course so you may invest in
more than one online course or you may
want to go
deeper everyone's saying more than one
book on one topic
so it's just proof i'm trying to make a
point i hope it's clear
competition is good people are
interested in a particular thing
they want to even go deeper on that
thing and so
even if you don't reach those same
customers it actually just kind of
proves the market's mentality
here's the key is there a market for my
own
online course are other people selling
courses on this topic oh
not that it's already saturated oh
that's actually evidence
that i should potentially lean in and
try that you to be strategy
and try just googling it your niche and
put online course
after it uh next
so to go deeper fulltimeinfluencer.com
only available for a few more days link
in the description down below or just
type that in
your url fulltimeinfluencer.com if you
got value today
smash the like button special stream
on a friday night and super grateful
uh to be able to hang out with you if
you're on the replay and you made it
this far
man you're you're right or die you're
super hardcore uh
i hope you got a lot of value took a lot
of notes it's time to take action
recapping our points number one
uh it's time to go all in because this
is a massively growing industry this is
gonna be a billion dollar
a day industry by 2025. the next four
years is going to be a crazy e-learning
movement it already is it's grown 900
percent
since the year 2000
and it's only going to continue to grow
so you want to ride that wave number two
it's low overhead and low margins it's
the best business model
and if you're teaching something online
positioning yourself
with expertise or a skill or teaching
how you to content anywhere on social
and particularly on youtube
number three it's the best business
model for youtube creators
especially that are on the education
how-to side but
i even saw recently a friend of mine he
does
viral tick tocks reels he does
content that's entertaining and he
created an online course about how to
create
viral and funny content for social media
so this is the summary friend
do the thing and then teach the thing
what is it that you do
heather taurus on think media team
homeschool she does homeschool
she can teach homeschool what is it that
i did i did videos since 2003
i started talking about tech in a fit
and online and earning money with
affiliate marketing
so i packaged it in a course on youtube
and taught people how to grow their
youtube channels and make money with
affiliate marketing i did the thing
first
then i taught the thing nicole kidzot
help
she is a kid's occupational therapist
raised a baby help some other moms raise
babies
helped with the tummy time teaches the
thing
flyride built a business making custom
headlights
making money and selling headlights
online and building a business in the
import car niche now he teaches how he
does it and he loves this
part too because there's something about
he's like man i'm not as much in the
garage grinding as much i've created
scalability by packaging what i know in
an
online course do the thing
and then teach the thing and if you want
to go a little bit deeper
and really study this weekend then jump
into
fulltimeinfluencer.com free course
course limited web class and then it
talks a little bit about
the program and the academy that i took
that really taught me a to z
everything that i know about online
courses and scaling from six to seven
figures
and all those different online courses
that i showed you about
25 or 30 different ones that i've done
uh because i just continued to see
it's all about figuring out what your
community needs next and how you can
help them next
and then answering that next problem and
in that in one sense it's not even about
the online course you create it's about
the courses
because you might make a mini course one
video one hour you might make a four
part mini
series eventually you might make an
academy a couple years later you
discover that people are going to
the next level i just invested in a
course called business made simple
just to learn one module of it on
negotiation
as i'm getting into negotiation really
real estate deals and other things
as i evolve my learning evolves and i'm
investing in future online courses this
is a major wave it's a major movement
the next four years it's going to be it
is already is a crazy wave i'm
encouraging you
ride the wave jump on i hope you got
value today
smash like make sure you're subscribed
liked and following
if you need any more value if we're not
connected on instagram yet
at sean cannell rhymes with youtube
channel or twitter and that's
should be sean cannell everywhere and i
would love to connect with you shoot me
a dmm
if you have any questions about anything
and in the meantime keep crushing it
keep smashing it
all weekend long phil's green says it
frills green do the thing and teach the
thing
little crafty nook i appreciate you
you're welcome and uh thanks so much for
hanging out heather appreciates you and
thanks for hanging out
um yeah yeah yeah jay never split the
diff i need to read that i got the audio
book and the book but i haven't read it
yet i know that's an all-time
negotiation book so i'm excited for that
as well
and uh love it appreciate you have a
great weekend and we will talk soon